on the surface this appears to be an
exercise in democracy but in Lebanon
politics is conducted outside the halls
of power and without any deal any chance
to elect the president is Slim no one
has a majority that's why we need to
align sometimes to get better results
alliances have changed since the last
vote in January the main Christian
parties have put their differences aside
and joined the wider opposition to back
Jihad azure
but it wasn't enough for the former
finance minister to win in the first
round fewer votes are needed in a second
round of voting but the Hezbollah LED
Alliance walked out before that could be
held
this is a confrontation between those
who want to State and those who want to
remain stronger than the state
the movement for a change in leadership
began years ago but the traditional
political class has held on to power
we have lost all hope in this political
system and I absolutely have no faith in
it that system is blamed for decades of
corruption that led to the collapse of
the economy
we have reached Breaking Point yet they
won't elect a president it seems the
decision to paralyze the country is
coming from abroad
lebanon's political factions are tied to
foreign powers whose rivalries are
played out here Lebanon could be facing
an open-ended crisis if politicians
don't come together and agree on a
consensus the country needs a president
to be able to appoint a government to
deal with the economy's collapse what
the 12th electoral session has showed is
that there won't be a president unless
he is a candidate that rival sides are
prepared to compromise on San Jose
Beirut